let's switch gears a little bit and talk
about video and in kind of live type
components twitter has or had at vine
obviously and it was growing it seems
pretty good that got shut down but now
tik-tok is like all the rage what's kind
of your thoughts there I mean the fact
that Twitter had vine it was working it
was popular with the right user base who
were creating content comedians the kind
of culture makers in this country and
they'd even started to add the music
features that tick-tock are now known
for the ability to sort of borrow the
audio from another video or using audio
clips that are designed for perfect
loops like Twitter had it all vine had
it all together and then just because
Jack Dorsey mismanaged the finances of
Twitter you know was running a bit too
tight on cash and was worried about
where did they were spending they just
decided rather than pay for the hosting
costs per vine we're gonna shut it down
and that I think will remain one of
these stupidest decisions in social
networking history because now we've
ceded control to this fundamental piece
of social networking to a Chinese
company which does not share our
country's ideals and values and the fact
is that this product is popular because
it is fun I use tik-tok every day
because it's incredibly entertaining
this concept of micro entertainment that
instead of is autobiographical stories
stuff that we're all getting a bit sick
of instead of someone spending 15
seconds to shoot something that we spend
15 seconds creating on tick-tock people
spend 2 hours 10 hours creating
something 15 seconds long - just densify
that entertainment and make it as
valuable for your per second as possible
and that's why these networks are
important and why micro entertainment
like Tiktaalik cannot be easily cloned
by Instagram or YouTube or Facebook
which are all building their own
versions Facebook lasso Instagram has a
thing called reels it's testing in
Brazil and just yesterday was revealed
that YouTube is building shorts but the
thing is you need a base of content to
remix in order for these networks to
thrive and any of them starting from
scratch are going to have a really tough
time you can copy all their features the
same way that Facebook copied snapchats
and did a very good job it was very
successful with that but with stories
you don't need any prerequisite contact
with tick-tock you have to have this
entire corpus of source material that
people can remix in order to make great
content and Facebook and Instagram are
just not going to have that they're
gonna come out of the gate flat-footed
the only hope is that YouTube unlocks
its massive archive of videos you know
the five billion plus videos that people
watch every day and make those available
for remix in their YouTube short SAP and
doesn't you know aggressively apply
Content ID and take down any video that
uses copyrighted sound I mean this is
promotional when somebody puts a song in
a tick-tock that's how will NAS X's Old
Town Road went to the top of the charts
don't take that stuff down so Google
could only succeed here if it
understands that needs to unlock its
database of videos and not police it too
carefully with Content ID yeah the
little NAS X story is incredible for
those they don't know when he basically
did was he created the song and then he
would look for videos or meat or gifts
that were kind of going viral and then
he would basically take that visual put
his song overlaid and then send it to
whoever was posting the original video
that was going viral and say hey use
this one and I think his big break was
uh he put that song overlay over what is
the duck the guy standing on the horse
like going really fast or something and
then the song blew up with the video and
next thing you know he's you know kind
of this global sensation simply by you
know really hacking together a song with
viral content exactly and that's what
you're not gonna see on these networks
that aren't designed for sort of this
this cross-sharing
the whole the atomic unit of tick-tock
is the remix you take the audio from
somebody else's video you shoot a new
video recontextualizing that joke and
suddenly you have something new without
having to be perfectly creative and
that's the best the real importance here
is you can lower the bar for creating
something truly valuable and watchable
through remixes and that's why I
tick-tock is so powerful and it's why
vine was so great in its era and why
it's gonna be so difficult for even if
Twitter words a we launched mine now it
would be really difficult to catch up
because they don't have that same back
archive
of content for remixes yeah it wasn't
there an issue we're like the vine
creators all I got together and I think
I remember reading an article there was
like a showdown between like Twitter
management and a bunch of vine creators
living on Vine Street in the apartment
or something right yeah absolutely so
you know Twitter never decided to
directly support vine stars they were
not good at bringing them in-house and
sort of giving them tutorials or helping
them meet the team or use the features
they were not great at connecting them
with brand deals and it just meant that
these vine stars were effectively
contributing all of this content for
free and getting nothing in return and
then the next big wave of social
networking is about monetizing and
helping creators monetize it's not about
just slamming people with ads it's
letting the people who make this content
share in the rewards that they're
generating and you know eventually vine
bought my cousin Darren lachman's
startup called niche and brought it
in-house so that it could help do these
deals and connect vine stars to brands
and then Twitter neglected niche and
eventually just sort of let it wither
and this is again this is like a
pioneering establishment in the
influencer marketing world and again
Twitter squandered its opportunity and I
think the fact that you know jack dorsey
has has consistently done this bought
something great like periscope which
have also failed to properly integrate
into the rest of its product and
eventually it really lost that use case
to facebook live that's what everybody
is doing all their live streams of their
concerts is on it's not it's not
periscope it's not Twitter live its
Facebook live because Twitter was
unwilling to go all the way and make a
drastic change and integrate periscope
directly into Twitter for so long then
into the same thing with fine and
collecting it and eventually shutting it
down
in the collected niche and I think at
this point you have to wonder does Jack
Dorsey still deserve this job and so
when there's these new corporate raiders
coming in saying if you don't get the
metrics up and do all this and all these
Twitter you know employees are fighting
for him saying oh no he's a great boss
he's a nice guy I've met him he's very
kind he's very empathetic he really
thinks through things but he's not
getting it done and that's what Twitter
needs right now a decisive leader so to
my questions were going to be to finish
the square
part of the conversation one do you
think that Twitter is a better product
today than it was three to five years
ago even in spite of all of the kind of
critiques I mean the product is
absolutely better specifically the
algorithmic time line makes it so much
easier to actually find the best stuff
you know the reason Twitter is special
is that it makes any or everybody as
smart as anybody it lets somebody take
all of the research all of the knowledge
all their wisdom from their life use
that as a lens for consuming new
information and then distilling it to
the most important parts that is a
fundamental part of our world we as a
species are so specialized we all live
such different lives and have such
different knowledge that we need a
product like this to be able to all
share in each other's wisdom right and I
think the algorithm timeline does a
great job of that and the 280 character
change does help that yeah sometimes it
makes it a little bit exhausting to read
Twitter but it's a lot less confusing
because you're not trying to thread all
these things together just to make a
pretty simple point that said Twitter in
the meantime has done very little to fix
its its safety problems it's allowed
them to just run completely rampant and
now when people think of Twitter they
think of getting attacked they think of
this celebrity's life that they've heard
of like Leslie Jones who've had to leave
Twitter because they've been so harassed
and they just think of the confusing
experience if you start a new Twitter
account today you will be dumbfounded
about how bad the onboarding experience
is they basically just show you a bunch
of celebrities say follow these people
and then dump you on the timeline they
don't teach you anything about what you
should tweet about how you steal
information from the real world and
share it they don't teach you about
digging into your specific niche
interests and finding the experts in
those areas rather than these totally
catch-all no comma lowest common
denominator celebrities and they don't
really teach you about how to interact
on the timeline how replies really work
how you know how any of these different
tools like retweets and fades really
affect your timeline and with that
people they get started they don't
understand it they feel like they're
talking to a black hole because they do
a very bad job of getting new users
followers and
say why am I doing this you know
Facebook's big metric has always been
how fast can they get you to ten friends
because once you have ten friends your
feed starts getting good and you stick
around Twitter or understood how to
prioritize that onboarding experience
and so it has hundreds of millions of
people who have tried Twitter at some
point and churned away and are now
soured on the platform and are a lot
less likely to ever come back because of
this rotten onboarding experience and so
if there was one thing that the Jack
Dorsey could still do to improve the
growth rate and maybe keep his job or
that a new CEO should come in and
prioritize right away is fix that
onboarding experience make Twitter
accessible to anyone so we can all be as
smart as anyone